- Okay.
Love you.
Everything is good.
Just sitting in way too much
traffic. I don't want to be
late for Johnson & Johnson.
Yeah, I will. I will.
Jesus.
- Agencies they lose their
clients, they're gone.
Media companies have clients and have
consumer-facing brand.
What's the punch line with this account?
You got a note this morning
from Gary that says,
"This scope is being taken
over by me and James."
If he says, "What's the deal with that?"
I think documenting
your journey on, again,
Medium, your own personal blog, YouTube,
SoundCloud, Anchor, you
know, on and on and on,
Snapchat, on and on and on
of you going through this journey,
it would be really cool
to have content right now
about when Vera Wang started learning,
like literally learning,
how to create a dress, right?
Too many people either
do A, what you think,
which is first I have to become it,
and then I can talk about it,
and I'll wait two,
three, four, five years.
I think what you need to do, today, stat,
is find the way you want to
communicate to the world,
and here's the punch line,
tell the world the truth.
Good, awesome, good luck.
That was interesting DRock.
Finding new ways to
bring value to DailyVee.
Mom, I think you should probably come on
and do one show with me.
You're not schmuck [speaks
Russian], you can do it.
Well, you should practice with DRock,
I'm gonna send DRock once
a week to your house.
You'll practice and then you'll come.
(laughter)
Good Papua, how are you?
Things are well.
Papua, Sunday night could you join me for
a Knicks' game, court side?
Just spoke with my Mom and Dad,
boy are they different,
but fuck do I love them.
I think we should stick it
to every body that razzed you
about AM/PM, and I think we should
easter egg an AM/PM
switch on every episode,
just to stick it.
But as like comedians or
musicians, sometimes you want to
play the whole...
- No, don't worry.
- Sometimes you want to play the concert,
and sometimes you want to do
the MTV Unplugged Acoustic,
yeah.
- You'll play...
- It's always predicated
on the size the room and
the amount of people.
- Yeah.
- I tend to stand up at some
point when I'm sitting down.
Hey, how are you?
- Robert Delgado.
- Such a pleasure. How are you?
- Welcome.
- Good, thank you.
- Glad you are here.
- Thank you for having me.
I'm stunningly confused by
the audacity of the marketing
industry and people to
call me a disrupter,
when all I want to do
is sell product, today.
I think it's time to
have real conversations,
because this isn't gonna get better.
- Nice to meet you.
(laughter)
Thank you.
- Ready?
- Good?
- Thank you, yeah.
Perfect timing...
- I do want a picture with Gary.
- Bye guys, thank you.
The big thing with me,
because I get so competitive,
is I need to always
make sure I'm balancing
humility with bravado,
because that's where you can lose them,
because they stop hearing you.
I'm proud that I'm the
actual practitioner,
against my own work.
DailyVee has been a big
win for me because now
people can actually see, in
real life, that I do work
15, 16 hours a day,
but what do I spend that time on?
I spend it on five minute
meetings with all my employees,
15 minutes doing HR with them,
I'm doing strategy with them.
I'm working. I'm working.
This Gary Vee character
that lives on social media,
that does motivational
quotes, and ra-ra rants,
and does the show, that's me,
but I'm equally spending
11, 12, 13 hours of my day
being an executive,
I'm an actual mechanic.
I'm inventing the next
version of the screw driver,
then I'm using it.
I would say that I'm
a believer of passion,
but I believe that passion
is very similar and a cousin
to happiness, and you need to have it
to actually be the trigger
to the tactics that are the
massive rationale to
why one is successful.
So when you say that
passion is the ingredient
that most matters to
success, I agree, but here's
how I think about it,
without passion, nobody...
If Tony Hawk wasn't passionate
about skateboarding,
if I wasn't passionate about
becoming one of the great
entrepreneurs of a generation,
if LeBron wasn't passionate
about basketball,
they wouldn't have put
in, I wouldn't have put it
the hours, the work.
When it all makes no sense,
when it's 10:30 at night
tonight and I gotta go
to one more meeting,
but I gotta wake up at 5:30,
and if I didn't have the
passion for the game,
I wouldn't do it. I would cancel it.
I wouldn't have booked
it in the first place,
and so it becomes the
gateway drug, religion,
that allows you to do the
tactical things, right?
I have a vision to where
we're going in the future.
I come up with stuff every
day, that very few people
are thinking about,
and then, in parallel, and this
is one of the biggest reasons
I still have a personal brand,
I use Instagram, and
SnapChat, and Facebook,
and Twitter, every single day.
I'm a practitioner. I get my hands dirty.
I'm the architect and the mason,
literally the acrhitect,
the general contractor,
and the mason.
That was great.
Wow, that was really great.
That could end up being the
best interview I'm going
to give on this book.
Hey everybody!
I don't talk to you
that often on DailyVee,
I don't know how we're
going to edit that because
I think you could probably
allude to the questions he asked.
You could ask me. I don't
know if I'll remember,
probably not, you know how we roll.
That felt really good.
That felt really, really good.
I want that to be in the
episode or if you want to take
that out and say why this
book is a separate video,
I was able to articulate
a lot of my feelings
about this book and that was exciting.
DRock wants me to tell
you the favorite moments
from yesterday's thing.
Super8, first of all
thank you guys so much for
being part of it, it was a lot of fun,
I really could see myself
doing that once a week.
(laughter)
What is this?
- What?
- Oh my God.
What is this?
I'll tell you what it is, it
is a bucket full of receipts.
I am fired up right now.
Bucket full of receipts,
when you pull in look,
oh my God this person, could you imagine,
(laughter)
you know what? I can't do
it. We're gonna do something
here for this person right now,
because this would be unfair.
This person is getting 10 signed books,
because that would be unfair if like...
no actually...
(laughter)
I don't know what to do.
- Do something with them that's fun.
- Okay, fine.
- Yay.
- Ten signed books for this
person, congratulations.
So they bought eight,
they're getting ten more,
signed books from me.
The winner is, you ready?
You know sometimes I do
things where I always make fun
of the fact my personal
brand isn't my business,
though it is for a lot of people,
which you know, kudos,
everybody do you. Don't do me.
A day like yesterday actually makes
me think about how cool
it would be if that was my
business, because that would be
fun to do once a week,
I just would love it.
So I don't want to give you
my favorite moments DRock.
What I want to do is
say that the whole thing
is my favorite moment, right?
Sure there's the part where
I'm singing Miley Cyrus.
(singing Wrecking Ball by Miley Cyrus)
Don't you ever say I just walked away,
I will always want you,
I came in like a wrecking ball!
(laughter)
Sorry, sorry, sorry I got excited.
That was fun. Sure the parts
of AJ that was super fun.
- You used to do flying elbow
of desks with a substitute?
- No I didn't actually elbow somebody.
- You elbowed the desk, right?
- No, I was telling the class that
I loved Macho Man Randy Savage,
so I stood on the desk in
the middle of class and
did the elbow, the flying elbow.
- Yeah.
- When you have people like Altucher...
You just hang out with sharks
or extremely, extremely
attractive dudes.
- I always say to the hooker
either sharks or people
more attractive than me,
(laughter)
which is basically the rest of the world.
- James' self-deprecation is all time.
- I also wet my bed since
I was twelve by the way.
- Bang.
That's me.
- Bed wetter's unite.
- Dude we should start a bed
wetters unite, you know what,
Andrew?
Pat, hold on one second,
this is important, Andrew?
I need you to start designing
right away a T-shirt
for my TeePublic, that
says Bed Wetters Unite.
(laughter)
- I can definitely do that.
- Thank you. I need it ASAP.
...and other marketing peeps.
- Where am I looking, at DRock?
- There's a lot of places to look.
- I'm a recovering corporate lawyer,
turned ultra-endurance athlete.
I've written a couple books,
"Finding Ultra," "The Plantpower Way,"
both bestsellers,
I've got a podcast I've
been doing for three years.
- That's super cool for
them, getting them exposure
to my community. I like
giving that to people and
giving them a chance to
meet different people,
for you the community,
for them, and vice versa,
showing up on their radars.
And interacting with the team,
getting to sit in a room with
India and Andy and you and
Garrett coming in and dumping
the sheets for the first
time and making the joke.
- Woah.
- Woah, Garrett, Garrett hold on!
Drew I'm sorry, Garrett you screwed up.
(laughter)
Garrett when we drop things
in the bucket we need
to make a huge deal about it.
It needs to inspire the
others that are holding out
and breaking my heart.
- How many?
- No don't ask him how many,
because I don't even want
to know now, Andy.
You took away my happiness
Garrett, and that's it.
You took my fucking happiness away.
Get out of here.
- Way to go.
- So pissed.
- It was a handful too.
- I don't...Staphon, don't
end up in Garrett category.
Okay hold on let's
- Sir.
- Okay this--
- A lot of action.
- This is action.
Oh my God, yes.
(laughter)
This is so good. I love this.
Garrett, you're redeeming yourself.
I could talk about the
different favorite things that
I had happen yesterday.
I could talk about that but
that's not interesting to me,
what's interesting to me is
just the fundamental fact that
A, that I'm so lucky, and I
know a lot of you say that
I work for it, and you get mad at me,
but so lucky that people care
enough to have a sick day,
to sit there and watch me for
eight hours or that I'm so
lucky to have a mom and a
sister, who watched a lot of it,
and called me and showered
me with compliments and
things of that nature,
and I'm so lucky that I
was born with the energy
to be able to that and then go out and
have four more hours of meetings.
Those are the things that really strike me
on days like that,
or that my dad will tell me the next day,
"Should I get a Facebook?"
because he wants to see
the nice things I said
about him and because my Mom
probably told him, you know
those are the things that
I really care about, on a day like that.
Hey brother, how are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- Good man, I got to just talk
to Higgins for the first time
since the meeting so sounds
like you got a little context
from what happened, right?
Understood, running into a
meeting. I love you brother.
Yeah of course, bye-bye.
11:14.
Thank you so much.
This new Facebook buttons thing
is going to be super interesting.
A lot more data, and we're
just like, a lot of emotions.
Sad, wow, haha, you can
be angry about my content.
It's going to be a lot more context
which is super important.
And will lead to a smarter
machine which will be deployed
against more opportunities to story tell,
so it will be fun to watch.
- Gary, for those of
you who on the phone Gary,
and his security detail just joined us.
- DRock is here, I do a
daily vlog, my whole life
is being documented for the
rest of my life. Don't worry,
nothing sensitive he can
approve it, it's B-roll.
(smooth jazz playing)